we've got the vibe in the office we had
it on the last episode last Friday we
were here late little drunk you didn't
matter didn't matter you were playing
this lil game called final approach that
I want to talk about and ty I think you
played it as well I'm just glad you
named it right I i can what did I keep
calling it like control flight control
like so final approach I'm going to give
us a cursory description you play God
wearing a glove that was made in the
tron universe and you tell helicopters
and planes were to go that's all I know
yeah and you and you extinguish them
when they catch on fire I fill me in why
is this so fun and why does it need view
it's it's just it's again I was probably
one of the biggest viewer skeptics until
we got this thing in the office yeah and
this is obviously one of the demos we
played but when you're in there it is
just it's i think this is Mary trying to
screw with the core pedestrians that
live in the city but Josh no it looks
awesome but the thing is it's it's hello
I'm gonna talking to the microphone you
can tell this is my first rodeo then we
behind the scenes Mary just had a heart
attack over there but it's just a really
you feel like you're Godzilla you don't
feel like you're God I feel like you
feel like you're just this giant you
know thing walking especially in the
city one but when you're in the you have
like an ocean level where you're like
just get it it's as simple as telling
helicopters and planes were to land
performing tasks someone catches on fire
you have to extinguish them look I'm
gonna stop it just sounds incredibly
boring yeah what listen I might just
been crazy no I mean like like what what
is what is the like making the plane
land or making it crash right those are
really simple experiences like how does
the overall thing like make you feel so
when I was what i will say is having you
know trying out the oculus rift having
tried out i think i was going i tried
out but regardless you put this thing
and you're at this is the first standing
VR thing I've ever done and I'm a little
skeptical because you know with like
deep with the dk2 we had me off
yeah um I don't know that thing I could
see the pixels ray I'm just sitting in a
chair it was enjoyable this however
you're standing and you're moving around
now no maybe out we I'm sitting in a
chair for the dk2 and all I'm you know I
have a controller in my hand it's it
hurts your head your head basically to
grasp okay i can look with my left or
looking with my head but my right stick
is still ingrained with like other
movement and tasks this however is like
full VR and well what I will say about
this one that the resolution is
top-notch I'm not I don't notice any
pixels the precision is what really got
me like stoked and as you said like kind
of like a Tron you have this armband
right I feel like I'm Tony Stark and
it's perfect like it's like a palette
and everything is so precise that you
you could do forever like I don't know
there's no motion sickness involved that
was a big complain with like they are
the precision was what like took me away
and you know you'll you'll have a plane
fly or direct a plane to like land right
and then you'll forget about and you
hearin your right speaker and he looks
you're right and there's a plane in your
face flying right past your eyes like it
is why does water physically amazing
it's always so hard to communicate what
makes it VR experience great because
it's not it's just not the same as
looking at it on the screen if you
really have to feel that sends a
presence yeah and this is our dilemma
right i mean like you how do you explain
this to somebody how do you show it to
somebody like that clip right there with
josh messing around and in their room
with the vibe on is it isn't it's not
indicative what that experience is
really like no at all whatsoever like
the only way to tell you about it is
just a gift experience it yourself yeah
it's like love no one can tell you
you're in love
yeah valve innocuous and anyone else
like Sony who's experimenting with VR
has a really tough road ahead of them
because they've got to get this stuff in
people's hands maybe it's gonna be word
of mouth that does it yeah you know oh
look a real aircraft stimulate hose it
down pilot I mean that game a look
boring as hell I mean if you just watch
it on this video no on this stream but
when you play it it's it's hard to
describe it just it feels really good
especially those other demos we had 20
urate there's somebody to talk about and
you know we are actually getting our
final oculus rift pretty soon the
embargo for that lifts the 28th and
we're gonna start having a whole mess of
VR coverage and it's gonna be it's gonna
be interesting to see how we do it yeah
yeah um what are your thoughts real
quick on the PlayStation VR do you think
I think is actually gonna come in under
500 bucks or not whoo I think right now
the kind of the guess is that they are
going to try to hit 500 because they
want to go beneath oculus won't be below
that but that's the thing though is that
Sony isn't just selling the headset they
have to sell a little box that's
connected to it that it does the extra
processing because the ps4 isn't doing
all of it no so you had that cost in who
knows but Sony as a console manufacturer
is known for selling Hardware at a loss
to get people in to buy the software
yeah the question is can that model work
for this given that people already need
to own a PlayStation 4 so there's a
whole other purchase so they have the
installed base which is good that's the
helps but it's asking someone to drop
another 500 bones on something that you
know I only have so many bones Sony
that's it started from Peter himself
it's the library right like that's the
selling point like what's the vibe going
for now 805 is 800 and that comes with
two controllers which the riff does not
the rift I think comes with an xbox one
thriller about a 60 controller and and
there I can I haven't I haven't tried
the newest version of the oculus but
that vibe was probably the best one I've
tried to date in terms of PlayStation VR
or the Morpheus whatever it was called
when I tried it and then oculus and this
that was great but you need a space for
that place to like we have like this you
know stri oh that's big but we live all
we also live in San Francisco and it's
like you know how big our apartments
here we all know it's not it's not
necessarily the best experience but you
need the room you need the room and
there were a couple of issues that were
frustrating right like you know you have
this cord
like neo matrix just like sticking out
of your head like unfortunately yeah
you're going to be you know losing track
of where you are as far as your rotation
is so like you know if you if you get
you get tangled basically the dog's age
yeah and um I guess I would say like man
maybe it would be probably really
imperative to like have this thing
attached to the ceiling or maybe maybe
they'll even have like an adapter or
some like that like some kind of like
bungee system yeah um I know how to see
this thing being like you know like the
mic at like a like a fight club ladies
and gentlemen drop it like its Josh that
could work if Josh was not here like
guiding me and and help assisting me
with that thing I would have been
hitting walls knocking over his sailboat
all this other crap I mean I've been
I've been bad well the interesting thing
about the vibe and I don't know if we
had accident at that time but it has a
camera that lets you see things in your
environment it does which is great when
you can make a wall you can make like
this like gridwall where it says you can
actually outline your room and be like
all right if I get to this edge that
means there is a object right in front
of me it will also sense like like just
any object in the road I've got that bad
yeah like I was at a demo once who they
told me to sit down and I was like the
hell I'm gonna set in there like look
down and I looked down and I could see
the outline of the chair so you knew you
were so I was able to sit down in VR
well I was still in the experience that
was looking there's just like a little
bit of a ghostly image yeah which helps
yeah the dawn of VR is upon us yeah are
you guys planning on buying a VR headset
do you have the money in the VR dungeon
everyone has the money they're just
loaded everybody oh it's high I don't
know how the hell people are gonna buy
these things I just I'm still skeptical
if they're gonna sell that well well
think about it and let us know in the
comments below if you're gonna pick this
stuff up we're pretty lucky we get them
in but man I could not afford this on my
own now 800 bucks in dollars there's
library and then you need the computer
run the damn thing yeah like we have
like a 980 in that thing and and it's
it's it's a beefy machine man talking
like $2,000 plus yeah so run nothing